[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
ya está daniel hablando con nosotros en
el estudio dan y vamos a hablar del
precio mundial de los alimentos que
sigue subiendo bueno raúl entonces le
explico primero la fao que es la
organización de naciones unidas para la
alimentación y la agricultura elabora
mensualmente un índice este índice
refleja la variación de los precios
internacionales de una canasta con los
productos alimenticios más
comercializados 5 para ser exactos en
marzo ese índice había alcanzado su
máximo histórico se está alejando de ese
máximo pues los precios en julio bajaron
8,6 por ciento frente a junio sin
embargo si se compara con el año pasado
siguen 13,1 por ciento más altos danny
hablemos entonces estos cinco alimentos
que más se consumen comencemos con
aceites vegetales su precio hoy es 19
por ciento más bajo que el mes pasado
pero 10 por ciento más alto que hace un
año como lo podemos ver en el gráfico
hay mucha oferta en indonesia que es el
mayor exportador de aceite de palma del
mundo y en cuanto al aceite de girasol
del que rusia y ucrania son grandes
productores pues los mayores precios han
desincentivado el consumo ahora vamos
con cereales bajan 11 por ciento frente
a junio de 2022 suben 16 por ciento si
se compara con el mismo mes del año
pasado el resultado es en parte una
reacción al acuerdo entre los dos países
en guerra para desbloquear los puertos
del mar negro los precios del trigo si
siguen una cuarta parte más altos que
hace un año y que decir del resto de los
productos bueno entonces vamos con el
azúcar que no ha tenido gran variación
gracias a que la producción en brasil ha
sido mejor de lo esperado los lácteos sí
valen hoy 25 por ciento más que el año
pasado una de las razones por las que
también hayan bajado porque si lo
comparamos frente a junio desde el 25
por ciento el descenso es que en verano
en europa y hay menor actividad en los
mercados y en consecuencia menos ventas
de leche en polvo y de mantequilla
finalmente le hablo de la carne de res
esa es la que normalmente presenta menos
variación hoy en día está casi igual
en julio y 10 más cara que hace un año
pero en este rubro las carnes de aves de
corral si están registrando máximos
históricos bueno dejamos ese tema un
lado para ir a otro tema que nos encanta
no por supuesto la batalla de twitter
con y lo más que danny está contra
demanda de hilo en moscú acusa a la
empresa de fraude así es raúl pues hay
expectativa por la publicación del
contenido completo de esa contra demanda
que interpuso el magnate contra la red
social por el acuerdo fallido con el que
más que pretendía comprarla por 44 mil
millones de dólares sin embargo ya los
medios especializados han comenzado a
revelarlo según the washington post el
considerado hombre más rico del mundo
acusó a twitter de fraude y aseguró que
ocultó información es necesaria también
que engañó a su equipo sobre la
verdadera base de usuarios entretanto
the wall street journal aclara que las
contrademandas de moscas se presentaron
de forma confidencial la semana pasada y
se revelaron el jueves por la noche en
un desde el agua que es el que adelanta
el juicio en octubre próximo
twitters ya presentó su respuesta a
moscú antes de que el documento se
conociera oficialmente en la extensa
presentación negó que hubiera privado al
multimillonario de la información que
necesitaba o que también no era
tergiversado los detalles sobre su
negocio vamos a ver cómo termina qué va
a pasar a cómo termina y también por ahí
dicen que realmente la intención de mox
nunca fue comprar esta compañía si eso
eso lo hemos discutido muchas veces raúl
parece que es así parece que es así
vamos a hablar de sustancia que llegó un
acuerdo laboral con su personal en
tierra se desbloquee entonces un poco
los vuelos en alemania claro y es que
todos sabemos que las aerolíneas en toda
europa están enfrentando conflictos
laborales en verano ya que la rápida
recuperación del turismo ha provocado
escasez de personal y también la
inflación vertiginosa ha llevado a los
empleados a exigir salarios más altos y
justos en el caso de lufthansa entonces
el conflicto derivó en una huelga la
semana pasada que provocó la cancelación
de más de 1.000 vuelos el acuerdo
incluye un aumento gradual del durante
18 meses en total será del 8,3 por
ciento para quienes ganen hasta seis mil
quinientos euros al mes y de 19,2 por
ciento para quienes están devengando
hasta dos mil euros asimismo para los
trabajadores con menores ingresos la
retribución horaria quedará fijada en
trece euros a partir del primero de
octubre por encima del mínimo legal
ahora tendrá que seguir mejorando pero
con los pilotos bueno danny vamos a
hablar ahora de los indicadores
económicos vamos a hablar
específicamente de wall street que abre
en rojo tras conocerse el dato de
desempleo que acaba de publicar el
departamento de trabajo la tasa de
desocupación bajó levemente en julio se
ubica en el 35 por ciento y el número de
desempleados es de 57 millones en este
periodo se crearon más de 500 mil
puestos de trabajo y todo esto es
importante porque indica que las cifras
del mercado laboral están ya en niveles
previos a la pandemia ahora usted se
preguntará por qué bajan las acciones si
la cifra de empleo está bien están bien
y es porque este mejor comportamiento
mezclado con una altísima inflación
ponen más presión a la reserva federa
para que siga subiendo agresivamente sus
tasas de interés y ya hemos dicho que
las tasas son el coco de las acciones y
lo que me pregunto danielle es que va a
ser mañana por el día de su cumpleaños
no sé no me han invitado todavía hacer
nada bueno vamos a invitar a toda la
reacción de acá a una cena y a celebrar
dani su cumpleaños mañana que la pasé
muy bien
32 o bien vividos no muy bien
la cifra del día los 32 años daniela
blandos 3
danny un abrazo muchísimas gracias como
siempre por toda la información
económica y por supuesto por el
cumpleaños mañana que la pasé muy bien
esperemos acompañar rentarse pasamos a
hablar de salud con marinas ardilla
[Música]